Good morning, John.
I have a frustration with one of the ways that the world works;
the more attention and money you have
the more you can use that attention and money to get more attention and money,
which is the way that attention and money consolidates.
This process makes things less equal,
it's just how it works,
and I fall into this trap because I have more resources now,
and I tend to want to push them towards the things that we're working on, whether that's SciShow or CrashCourse or Dear Hank And John.
As I will be doing that next week for a thing that I'm excited about
(listen to next week's Dear Hank And John if you want to know more about it)
I'm going to right now turn some of the attention that is on me onto things that I
FREAKING LOVE
1: the Brain Scoop - just really love it and Emily is amazing
If you haven't checked it out lately, do that!
2: The Applied Science YouTube channel
Watching this guy try to take a picture of Toothpaste with an electron microscope is almost
as entertaining as watching him build a refrigerator that is cooled by rubber bands.
3: Super Sam Stuff and also so many other vloggers that are REALLY good
every time I find somebody like Sam I get super excited
4: (we're going to do some podcasts in the middle here): Tanis
It's amazing and creepy and lovely and weird, and I can't say anything more than that without ruining it.
Criminal: there's a lot of really great crime podcasts out there; this is my favorite one, personally.
6: You Must Remember This, with Corinna Longworth. She's so good. She's so smart.
She knows so much, and the history of Hollywood is so fascinating and also applicable to my life.
And number 7: my last podcast, Humanized Me
which is a podcast of like secular community building and also other stuff by a guy who was formerly a big deal in the Evangelical Christianity community.
8: Steven Septic and also all of the other former sourcefed hosts
But Steven's content is so weird and great and hilarious
9: Evylyn from the internet who always makes me laugh
But also, I feel very welcomed into her content and also like it gives me a chance to see stuff from a different perspective
10: ZipNap - Linguistics and stick figures
11:  Lindsey Ellis who always makes me laugh
She has really strong community and she always has amazing takes on
whatever content or cultural things she's talking about.
12: this one video from a channel that has a bunch of great videos
But it's called: "How does do science" it is the best video that could exist on how science works
13: Miles Chronicles don't drink while watching this chan..
I mean like any like not like get drunk. I mean like don't drink and you'll spray and choke
it's hilarious and of course no list of
Underappreciated Media would be complete without the great: Gunnarolla.
there's so much great creation in the world and we are Definitionally going to miss out on most of it
a lot of it's going to happen in languages we don't understand in cultures that we're not a part of in places we'll never go or see
as an example the first time I watched Kedi; the background just for a moment
I saw this piece of graffiti, this street art, and I'm a sucker for street art for good design
For cats and the image struck me so hard that I was like I what I talked to this person
I would have put that cat on a shirt, and I want to sell it
I want this person to get paid where they never thought they were going to be paid for their really
Amazing art you may have even noticed me shouting into the void of social Media being like can
Anyone get me in touch with this person
I tried like 30 different ways I got within one degree of separation four or five different times
I talked to people who knew him or had known him and
Couldn't get in touch with him right now and so I gave up
I was bummed about it, but I gave up and then a couple of weeks ago
I got an email and in the subject line nothing in the body in the subject
I said I am turkish street artist Ketut is Dead, and we are now selling his product on dftba.com
There's a week-long
pre-order different shirt designs both of them on a unisex or a woman's cut and also a lapel pin of the original cat that I
First saw I love that are newly
Connected more global society gives us an opportunity to see more of the cool creations and for more people to create
Professionally, and I think that we should work to take advantage of these really cool
opportunities that this connection
Brings us John there are links to all of the things that I talked about that I super super love down in the description
I hope that you people check them out and love them too, and I will see you on Tuesday